Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P
here is a really great question about the recent
medical drama that I talked about yesterday,
including the C-section, birth of my daughter
and the rehospitalization of my girlfriend
for a perforated duodenum. Duodenum.
People were emailing me saying, Sorry,
you're pronouncing it incorrectly.
Speaker 3: Nuclear proliferation.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I'm doing my best
with pronunciation. Anyway, here's
an interesting question about the entire thing.
Speaker 3: Hey, David. I love your girlfriend is
all right, but I have a question. I don't know
what type of health insurance you guys have
run an independent business. Correct. But how much
did all this cost? How much were you billed for?
The last time I went to the hospital, they charge
me $10,000 to go 5 minutes down the street.
Yep. Fortunately, though, I was on Medicaid at
the time, so I didn't have to pay for any of it.
Speaker 1: This is a great question. We have not
gotten any bills yet. Okay. I do plan to open up
the books like I did after my appendectomy.
You might remember my appendectomy. It was
about 40 grand, of which I had to pay my $2,000
deductible. Okay. So. Indeed, both. Both of us
are self-employed, and so we buy insurance from
our state's marketplace. When back during my
appendectomy, when I was in Massachusetts, I
bought I had a plan I purchased through what's
called the mass health connector. New York State
has a similar thing through which we now have
our plans called My State of Health. These are
not the best plans. Okay. So my expectation is
that we are going to owe the $2,000 deductible
for the birth and that Associated Hospital stay,
the $2,000 deductible for the rehospitalization,
for the surgery. And then because of the ambulance
call, I think that we probably have like a man,
it's probably a $500 co-pay for the ambulance
ride like these plans. These are not cheap
plans and they also cover very little. So
that's what I expect. Oh, I think our
we're going to owe somewhere between four
and $5,000 for all of this. I think the billed
amounts could could probably get to $250,000.
My understanding is that C-section, birth and
subsequent hospitalization can be 80 grand or so.
And then the surgery plus like a six day
hospitalization after that in I think it's
considered subacute care. I don't really know.
That could be another that could be 100 grand
one way. I think that the sort of sticker price
on everything is going to be somewhere around
200,000, could even be a little bit higher. We
will see. And I expect we will go somewhere around
four or 5000. So I'll open the books when we get
the bills. I haven't gotten them yet. I'll keep
everybody posted. We've got a great bonus show for
you today with some horrible stories, by the way.
One positive thing is Elizabeth Warren says
Democrats are only two votes away from codifying
Roe v Wade. Is it too late? Well, we'll talk about
it. Stacks of bodies have been found dead in a
trailer on the US-Mexico border. Horrifying story.
And a study finds that cannabis users are 25% more
likely to need emergency care or hospitalization.
But the question is, is it because of their
cannabis use or is it that people more likely
to need emergency care and hospitalization
are more likely to use cannabis, which would
be a very, very different explanation. All of
those stories and more on today's bonus.
Speaker 3: Show, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves as.
Speaker 1: Well. I invite you to sign up at
join pacman dot com. Get instant access to
the David Pakman show bonus show.
Speaker 4: Thank your lucky stars
every day. You're not Dave Pacman.
Speaker 1: Well, it's not that bad,
Alex. Thank you very much. Coupon code big
voting 22 sign up it joined Pacman dot com.
I will see you on the bonus. Yes.